I have a great admiration for garage
chess and I've only played him once in
the Blitz game and tournament and you
know it will be special to increase my
my good score
I I don't think I said he couldn't win I
mean obviously it's going to be very
interesting I think
um unlike most of us that Gary played in
when he was a professional player he's
probably not the clear favorite that
that much is certain but you know it's
gonna be an interesting event I think
all of us really want to beat him quite
badly and so I think he's gonna have his
work cut out for him
yeah
um just now I realize that it's serious
yeah it's just listening to all the
establish from Hikaru and I understand
no it's uh
clip of a tank of every player here so
and I will be sort of the you know the
most desired prey in the history of
chess